if you have cancer your doctor may
recommend chemotherapy as part of your
treatment the cells in the body grow and
divide as part of the normal cell cycle
the cell's nucleus controls this process
inside each nucleus genetic material
called DNA contains the instructions for
directing this process
sometimes the cells DNA becomes damaged
normally the DNA responds by either
repairing itself or instructing the cell
to die
in cancer however the parts of the cells
DNA that direct cell division become
damaged
when these sections are damaged the DNA
is unable to repair itself or cause the
cell to die instead the unrepaired DNA
causes the cell to grow and divide
uncontrollably into more damaged cells
called cancer cells
a tumor forms as the cancer cells
multiply and displace the normal cells
as the tumor enlarges it develops its
own blood supply
since cancer cells do not stick together
as well as normal cells they may break
away and enter a nearby blood vessel
cancer cells in blood vessels may travel
to other areas of your body and form
additional tumors this is called
metastasis additional tumors may form in
areas such as the lungs
liver
and bones
another way cancer may spread to other
areas of your body is through your
lymphatic system
cancer cells may enter lymph vessels
near the tumor then travel to small
glands called lymph nodes if the cells
pass through the nodes they may continue
to travel through your lymphatic system
and form additional tumors
chemotherapy drugs work by targeting
fast-growing and reproducing cells a
characteristic common to cancer cells
the tumor shrinks as the cells stop
dividing and die
most chemotherapy drugs work
systemically as they travel throughout
your body in your bloodstream as they
circulate the drugs damaged metastatic
cancer cells in other organs
unfortunately chemotherapy drugs cannot
tell the difference between fast-growing
normal cells and cancer cells as a
result these drugs also damage or
irritate some of your fast-growing
normal cells such as those in your bone
marrow digestive system and hair
follicles
death irritation or damage to these
normal cells produces side-effects such
as a weakened immune system nausea and
hair loss
the goal of chemotherapy is to reduce or
eliminate cancer cells in the original
tumor and any sites of metastasis in
addition to being a primary cancer
treatment doctors often use chemotherapy
as a secondary treatment before during
or after other primary cancer treatments
such as radiation therapy or surgical
excision of a tumor depending on the
location and type of cancer you may
receive chemotherapy drugs intended to
circulate throughout your body including
pills capsules or liquids taken orally
and intravenous or intramuscular
injections alternatively you may receive
drugs delivered only to the area of the
tumor one local method delivers drugs to
your bladder or chest through narrow
tubes called catheters another local
method injects drugs into the
cerebrospinal fluid surrounding your
brain and spinal cord
a third local method places slowly
dissolving wafers into an area where a
tumor was removed
in most cases you will receive a number
of different chemotherapy drugs to
increase their effectiveness you may
receive many chemotherapy treatments
spread out over a period of weeks or
months this allows your body to recover
between treatments and to kill as many
cancer cells as possible
common side effects of chemotherapy
include hair loss nausea decreased
appetite fatigue anemia bruising and
diarrhea
it is important to rest eat nutritious
foods and take medications prescribed by
your doctor to reduce or minimize these
side-effects